yeah you know live chair
thank you good morning everybody welcome
to the plans committee meeting
as the 23rd of july and those of you who
may be watching on the torres
youtube site welcome i'll ask them
the committee to introduce themselves
first of all
and then the office is your presence as
well so
i'll start i'm chair of the committee
with chris leather
and i'm a northern ward member
richard wiseman i represent the
chevrolet award
ruth craigie and representative
eastwater
good morning i'm captain robert i
represent great titan
vice chairman of the council
pete watson uh my word is brody
good morning captains of rosemont and i
represent two rivers
and three wars good morning council
david bernie representative
substituted for councilman
uh good morning members members of
public my name is sean harrington and
i'm the planning manager of toronto
council
good morning my name is david hunter and
i'm with services manager
good morning my name is tracy blackmore
i'm a development manager team leader
michael newton from denver council
science
and we've got our club
thank you so that's that's everybody
who's present
well there's no apologies plus agenda on
the items apologies for absence
the boxful team here this morning so
there are no apologies i've taken
yeah yeah councilman
apologist was counsellors
item two on the agenda is the minutes of
the last meeting
on the third of june and that's on pages
five
to fourteen agenda and i'll move those
from the chairs
[Music]
that's
thank you
um
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interests when the item is being
considered
elected members of devil county council
and town
parish councils who've considered a
planning application by virtue
of their membership of that council
called the personal interest
and are deemed to have considered the
application separately
and the express views of that council do
not bind the members concern
who consider the application of fresh
item foreign agenda between
parts one and two there is two
item six is public petition
participation
we've had requests to speak to
four applications for the creamery site
at torrington at
councillor doug smith on behalf of
torrington town council
david jobs speaking against the
applications
jan left bridge in support i believe is
is the architect that's project of the
applications
under statement from board member
councillor kotlin huntkin
which the planning manager will read out
the public participation scheme of irish
members of public to speak but the
the running order to speak is the
planning office will give
their presentation of the application
and then after that any term or parish
counsellor
who wishes to speak can speak for three
minutes on
and after that we allow two members of
the public
who may wish to speak against an
application
owned by two members of public and they
wish to speak in favor
of an application of their three minutes
each as well
finally award members are able to speak
at the plans committee and there's no
time limit on their
contribution
right okay we've moved on an item seven
on the gender
planning applications the information
recommendations and advice contained in
the reports
are correct as of the date of
preparation
which is more than 10 days in advance of
the committee
due to these time constraints any
changes
or necessary updates to the reports will
be provided in writing
or of a commission
and our first application this morning
is 7
8 on pages 15 to 21
it's proposed extensions and alterations
um and the presentation of this is
chasing
that one thank you chair
so this is a full application for the
proposed extension and alteration to the
existing clubhouse and changing rooms at
great toronto football club
the applicant and the application is
poor members due to the applicant being
a member of staff at torres district
council
there are no updates for members since
the publication of this report
this is a location plan with the site
outlined in red
as you can see the application site is
located to the eastern edge of great
origin directly south of the b327
next slide please this is a satellite
image the site is indicated with a blue
arrow again this image shows the site in
conjunction with the built form of great
toronto directly south of the b327
next slide so this is the existing
elevation um of the clubhouse the top
drawing
um to the left shows the existing
changing rooms
and to the right um it shows the
existing function room and bar area of
the clubhouse
this is the existing floor plans again
to the left showing the existing
changing rooms
and to the right is the existing
function room and bar
area of the clubhouse onto some faces of
the site
so this photo is looking west i have
just walked in from the access
and shows the front elevation and side
elevation of the existing clubhouse
another photo looking east this time is
showing again the front elevation and
the access which leads out
from the side onto the b327
this photo is of the rear elevation of
the changing room
as members can see the site is level and
screened by mature trees
for normal boundary and this is another
fascia of the rear elevation
showing the existing function and bar
area to the rear and another photo
this time looking west this time again
showing that rear elevation
so this is just a photo taken from the
street scene just to show members the
mature boundary treatment to the
roadside so this is from the b327
behind the hedge and established trees
are the changing rooms in clubhouse
but as you can see the mature treatment
boundary treatments effectively screens
this from the roadside
so moving on to the proposal
the proposal floor indicates the
extension is to extend the full length
of the rear of the existing changing
rooms
and function room the proposed extension
will
as i say do the foot that have been the
full length of the building which
measures approximately 41.14 meters with
a width of 3.9 meters and a roof height
of 2.9
meters the proposed extension is to
provide the club with some additional
changing
facilities taking it from two existing
changing rooms
to four changing rooms alongside
additional shower and toilet facilities
the club has around the existing
changing room and there is a growing
youth team
where they are requiring more facilities
now been able to
develop and grow their their clubs
the proposal also extends the existing
function room and kitchen
allowing the club to attract larger
functions
so this is the proposed elevation i
think this the side and rear
which is the middle and bottom drawing
to show the external changes
the front elevation which is the top
drawing remains near enough
the same the materials of the
construction will consist of rendered
block work and applied memory roof
and just moving on to this is just a
section drawing of the side elevation
which
shows the proposed rear extension to the
right
so moving on to the main planning
considerations of this application
so if we start the principle of
development the proposed development
will provide an extension to the
torrington rugby and football
club clubhouse which is a valuable
well-used community
facility the principal development
therefore meets policies st06 and sc-22
of the north eminent original plan
impact on character and appearance the
proposed single story extension to the
rear consists of a modern flat roof
extension
although this type of extension would
not normally be encouraged the proposals
as members will have seen
is well screened from the station's
street scene and public realm
the proposed extension consists of a
subservient element to the existing club
house building
therefore the proposal was considered to
record the policies fco4
and dm04 in fact on immunity the site is
located a sufficient distance from any
third-party properties
to ensure there will be no harm in
respect to any immunity issues
highways um there are not so no proposed
changes to the highway access
and the proposed extension would not
significantly change the nature of
traffic attraction
site drainage the foul drainage is to be
connected to the main sewer
and the surface water has to be done via
a safer way
ecology an ecological assess impact
assessment has been submitted in support
which concludes there will be no impact
on any protected species
a bird box is to be incorporated as part
of the proposed in relation to
biodiversity
and just on to other matters there is a
public right away that runs through part
of the site
however this proposal would not directly
affect the footpath
and informative has been added to ensure
that the public provides away remains
open
and available at all times during
construction phase
for this reason the recommendation is
one of approval
thank you thank you tracy
um yeah i think it's been encouraging
that there is a sports club within
torrington
that can see a future and are prepared
to invest in the future
i can't i think it fits all criteria in
the plans
um so i would recommend approval as per
the officer's report
thanks thank you councillor
yes and this is obviously
thank you nobody else wants to
speak on this application it's been
removed to
grant five councillors sending by
councillor watson
can we go through the vote on that all
those including
[Music]
that's unanimous thank you
all right our next application
our next application
which is the question we've got four
applications
to do with the credentials
[Music]
application the first application itself
you'll notice at 7b there's a
comprehensive agenda report
that helen planning officers put
together which kind of pulls on those
four applications an overview of
four of them how they relate to each
other we've got three
full applications and one in arizona
this morning
they've all got to be considered
separately because of course they are
separate applications of course we all
realize the importance
is the overall scheme of things
i'm sorry we just have a few minutes to
bring your videos
before we discuss their questions just
in a few minutes
cleaning things
okay
yes
[Music]
um
right um there was a bit of a high
interest there where we had to get the
members of the public
in uh and clean everything before the
we're all safely distanced in here this
the comprehensive agenda report that you
put together
will get whether you want to start with
that
and then go on to that first application
yeah and leave it up to you because it's
all
a piece of work that's been done yeah i
mean just just before i start i'll i
guess if i just explain how i intend to
do it just check your happy chair
um so the comprehensive agenda report as
you're aware is sort of
a summary of the four applications and
the necessary comprehensive approach and
makes
a comprehensive plan and balance at the
end um i'll only be doing
one comprehensive presentation rather
than four separate presentations but
the presentation will clearly define
each of the four applications which we
will then have to come
to for determination individually
so the one presentation will cover
everything and immediately follows
this this item i then have
each individual application where the
requirement is indicated for the debate
to be taken
under each of those separate headings
i've i've
included the main planning
considerations and the layout just so
that we've got it for reference
i mean in terms of discussion on the
merits i don't know whether
the idea or the presence would be to
have a comprehensive discussion
after my presentation or whether
because everything is so interlinked or
whether as we go through each
application
um for the votes
that's best that's best done well
yeah because the speakers i think will
come after the comprehensive
presentation
[Music]
yeah okay so
um good morning members and it's very
good to see you all in person
um so this
these four applications which um the
references are 105
24 20 20 f2lm 101
forward slash 0526 2020 fulm
and then we have one forward slash 0528
2020
remm which is a reserved matters
application
and then finally outline application one
forward slash one two three one
2018 from utm so
um as explained at the virtual site
visit
the four applications to form a
comprehensive master plan approach
um so a totality of 173 dwellings
incorporating some retail strategic open
space
and associated infrastructure um
the these four applications are tested
comprehensively so
hence the nature of the comprehensive
presentation
and we'll see that move is the
recommendations if
members are minded to prove that there
is a need to consider all together
because there will be implications of
one
not being approved because there are
those clear linkages
and the need for a comprehensive
legal agreement time together so just
starting with the
the aerial photo which shows the site
outlined in red at the bottom
southwest corner and just shows the site
in the context of greater torrington
and as you'll see it's down in the in
that southwest corner
um of the main center of great timeton
the total redline site area is
approximately nine hectares
um the majority of the site is a former
torrington creamery which ceased
operation
in the mid 1990s
you'll see it's a mix of brown filled
and green filled
and land and you have direct access from
the b327 limeless hill
which is just to the east the river
torridge
immediately to the south of the boundary
you have
chad port beyond to the south over over
the teleport bridge
um and you have the sort of eastern
sort of western fringes of great
targeting so mill street
just a medium to the east of the site
and the the public right of way royal
road
and
um the redundant buildings on the site
are in an incredibly poor state of
repair
they um there are significant health and
safety issues
as well with them much of the site is
derelict
there is a small um relatively small
existing commercial operation
immediately
um call it to the western part of the
site and again i'll come on to that
in some more detail into the
presentation the
part of the site benefits from a hybrid
commission which is granted in 2017 by
the firm's committee
that allowed 13 dwellings in full which
is the very northeastern
green field on the bends there nimros
hill
and 136 dwellings an outline 200 square
meters of retail a bat house
and then 1300 square meters of
employment
this hybrid commission has been
implemented um however there are a
number of conditions that need to be
discharged before
any development can take place beyond
the limited demolition that's being
allowed
and one of the applications before the
reserve matters is pursuant to
to that hybrid commission um
since 2017 and the
the applicant along with the adjoining
landowners so beyond
the the scope of the hybrid commission
have been working together to attempt to
deliver a viable scheme
i mean this site has been redundant for
20 years now
and this comprehensive approach is
considered to be
a deliverable prospect for the
redevelopment of the site
so this this is just um quickly a slide
that just shows a bit of site context
and site
analysis the foresights are outlined in
red
you can see that sort of central section
running through
the derelict buildings the public right
of way runs between them
which is roll road and there are further
further rights of waste you can see the
various green dotted lines
you have one running along the river to
the south
and a series of pathways and networks
upon the torrington commons which are
immediately
to the north um so that just shows that
existing
relationship with public rights playing
people enjoying
this sort of western part of of
torrington
there are quite significant trees
hedgerows
particularly along the northern boundary
of the site there is a bridal way
immediately to the north
and then the commons beyond the levels
also changed across the site you can see
the faint lines on this aerial photo
that sugar contours
so the commons lander burger is actually
much steeper a much higher level
limas hill does just end quite
quite steeply and there is still that
change in level and radiant
across the wider master plan site as
well
and
so i'll just run through each individual
site site and we'll just propose for
each of the four applications
so this firstly is application0526
2020 it's a full application um it's
the site that that's known as torridge
veil
it extends to approximately 2.7 hectares
um
to shame the aerial photo now just to
describe specifically this site
again you'll see that there is the large
storage valve
dairy building this is redundant within
that's
the northern bit of this site that
didn't form part of the hybrid
commission
so that that element isn't there is a
slight overlap
um with the the the site location for
the hybrid commission but predominantly
that
toyota valley boarding didn't form part
of that hybrid commission
um there are also you can see parts of
buildings that
the the red line cuts across um
and you can see that roll road extends
through the middle
secondly this is the reserve matter site
that has been brought forward pursuant
to
the hybrid commission so this is 0.528
of 2020
and this essentially is the main
creamery site it's
the reserve matters is brought forward
pursuant to the hybrid commission this
is a smaller red line
than that hybrid commission redline but
that's that's perfectly acceptable
and in terms of procedure and process
the points of access from nimitz
through the hybrid commission um next
time
you just see on the aerial photo there
that this this
application site is predominantly
redundant buildings and hard standing
and some of these buildings are of a
very significant scale
this is the third of the applications oh
five to four of 2020
this status name is high bridge house
this is a devon county council site
um there is it's just under 0.6 hectare
this site has a eastern boundary onto
limas hill
significant um tree boundary along the
north and you have the
public broad away immediately to the
north of the site
next time just showing the aerial photo
so so you can see that the redundant
building that
is on site and the rest of the site is
very much overgrown
scrub with the trees
and hedges forming quite distinct
northern and eastern boundary to the
right away
and lime as hell
and finally application 1231 of 2018
this is a major
outline application um known as the
southwest water site
and again you can see that access to
this site
is it's reliant on the reserve matters
scheme
and that access that's been already
approved by the hybrid commission coming
in off of limas hill
this is um
former southwest water treatment works
which open that northwest corner and
then it consists of
three parcels of agricultural land which
are
um currently put to agricultural museums
grazing and and taking hay
from it as with the high bridge house
site there is this
sort of strong mature tree hedge ray
boundary running along there
we'll call it the north um which
and then you have roll road forming the
boundary to the south of that site
so this is the um this is an extract
from policies
map five of the north devon torridge
local plan
so this is the proposed map of great
toronto
um the area in pink is the the majority
of the comprehensive
um sites that before you for
consideration
the this allocation is gtt01
in the in the local plan and it
allocates this site for 190 dwellings
um the supporting text indicates that a
range of uses
ideally would be secured through this
allocation
um but it's also very clear that the
focus should be on housing
um strategic leisure recreation and
employment for local needs so there are
three key uses that form part of the
policy allocation
um you'll see from this that part of
application 8526 so the torridge bell
site
sits outside of the policy allocation
the large building
you can see is within the development
boundary which is the dark the dark line
um and that is where development is
proposed
the the area that's proposed for open
space that stretches down as far as the
river that is actually outside of the
development boundary however no built
development is proposed
on that part of from that part of the
site
um in that wider context you'll see that
um policy gtt06 which
um concerns local green space and and
primarily the great toronto commons and
conservatives land so the dark green is
all in fact
you'll see the fight adjoins that
particularly on that northern boundary a
bit there's a bridal way that runs
through the middle
and there is then a relationship at that
sort of northwest corner
as well
um setting up a slightly further context
as well in terms of lists of buildings
and then
heritage the brown area is the
[Music]
the town centre conservation area and
you see there's a number of listed
buildings up within the town centre
the site doesn't hold a strong visual
relationship with the town centre
and the conservation area there are
however
um a relatively small number of listed
buildings on the eastern
side of the site so you have tada port
bridge itself which is protected and
there is a listed building on either end
of that bridge
and then the list of buildings with the
closest relationship of the site are the
ones
around the corner
this is an extract from the environment
agency flood zone mapping
the pretty much all of the
master planned site that falls to the
south of railroad is within flood zone
three which is the darkest shaded area
and partly in flood zone two
and this is this is the map that was
including the ecology survey
and it just shows the the habitats that
are on site at the moment
um predominantly you have the buildings
and the hard surfacing there
as as considered in the hybrid
commission there there is evidence of
facts within a number of those buildings
a lot of the buildings are connected
through
underground tunneling as well so there's
a there's a
the way the bats move around them
there's kind of a connection between all
of them
that was looked at very carefully in
regards to the hybrid commission and
there would need to be separate licenses
secured european protected species
licenses before any works can take place
um
the hybrid commission also has
conditions on it requiring mitigation
for ecology that said a whole new
comprehensive community survey has been
undertaken for the master plan
and additional surveys for the southwest
water site
um so in addition to the the buildings
you have
um areas of scrub most notably with the
hybrid
house site and at the very northwest
corner um where the the former
treatment the southwest water works are
you have um poor semi-improved
grassland where the agricultural land is
and
there is a badger set highlighted on
along the hedge boundary
um the most up-to-date survey indicated
based on a few visits to that badger set
that it was actually redundant so that's
classed as a
normal habited um badger set now
although the surveys do recommend
checks are made before any development
this is an extract from the transport
assessment and it just gives a very
simple sort of
distance from the site in terms of
walking
so the blue line is the 800 meter
distance
which does just take the site up into
the town center
with a wider distance of 1600 meters
beyond that um you should however
emphasize
um certainly those of you know the site
well but it is a very
deep gradient up to the town centre so
that must be appreciated in terms of
any you know potential for walking which
is a steep road up
mill street up to the town centre
um these public rights ways that all of
the people like the various
public rights were in and around the
site consistent with the aerial photo
that you were shown earlier
so much many of them are within the
commons land
roll road through the center and the
public right of way
through um along by the river um the
the public rights away officer has been
consulted on the various applications
and their comments are on your agenda
report
and so i just went through some of the
the views the photos looking towards the
side these are taken from the landscape
visual impact
assessment um firstly this view
the first the top ones from teleport
bridge looking across to the side you
can see those
those main bulk of the side redundant
and creamery buildings and the the
current sort of open space that
interacts with the river and the public
right of way
comes along there and then further
around to the west of tata portland v327
that view visitors get as they approach
torrington from the south of the
buildings on the other side of the river
these are these
and then from the village hall which is
a slightly sort of elevated
part of the highest part really of
teleport you can see that certainly that
main
tall really tall structure within within
the creamery
is very visible and you can appreciate
that context of
scale compared to the dwellings
certainly
um that lead up on the street and and
behind
and so these are further away
so further to the south the top photo
um taken from a
public road up the hill to the south
again showing the setting of the
creamery buildings within the
the valley and the relationship with the
town the
photo below shows that from that
particular public right of way
due to topography and also existing
trees you can't actually see the site
from there
this is from up within the commons and
the top one is from lima's hill
the road as you move down showing the
relationship indeed from the north
and again from the commons so that
network of paths that
are very well used within the great
terrain scenario and the visibility of
the site from those paths
and this is a host of you now from um
within the site that just in from niners
limitless hill and and showing them
the most visible part of the site from
from that part of the road
finally this um shows the relationship
of the site of the open space that's
currently alongside the river
um the public right away is that sort of
thin track that you can see
moving through the grass there um
and there is a very close relationship
between that public rights way and the
buildings just on the other side of the
hedge
it's just running through some further
site photos now
these will move from the the southern
part of the site so
application site oh five to six which is
the torah trail site
logically through through the site to
the reserve matter site hybrid house and
then southwest water
so this is a further view from from
teleport bridge showing
the relationship of the buildings to the
river
and and the overgrown nature of that
open space at the moment
again just a slightly different angle
this is on the north side of that bridge
this is on the public right of way just
looking back towards teddy bear bridge
so
the buildings aren't in sight from this
view but it's just to show that the
current sort of
overgrown nature of that environment
and again similarly this is looking
worse so the
the open space down to the river isn't
very accessible aside from
from the narrow footpath
and this is just to the side of the
footpath you can see that the buildings
can the buildings on the south side of
railroad can be viewed
again that's the existing footpath
this is the building that is proposed to
convert house
and there are plans which i'll show
later this is within
the open space area
and again that shows the sort of the
imposing nature of the buildings in
relation to the public right of way and
the area that is used to become public
open space
there are various areas of hard standing
which and that this particular one has i
think it's a burnt out vehicle on it but
there's very small um
fires that have happened and this is one
of the buildings to the south of
railroad
it's just this is the point of access
the lower access this shows the list of
buildings in relation to the the
existing
redundant creamery buildings
slightly sort of alternatively so you
can see where the access comes in
and roll road goes through the gap in
those buildings and again that
relationship that the list of buildings
hold with the creamery buildings that's
existing
now just sort of closer moving into the
site so
this is let's walk around here and
connect in with railroad
and then this is roll road itself so the
redundant building's
very close up on either side of railroad
so this is looking towards the east
this is one of the main central
buildings i would highlight
to members the the existing sort of mix
of materials
you've got brick and render elevations
the the window details because when i
come to show you the proposed
dwelling elevations and the retail and
apartment block
you can see that there's quite a strong
reference back to this this context
within the site
then looking further west you've got
torridge bell
building
[Music]
trail building on the right hand side
again that's looking east
and this is the crossrail road up
towards the north with the commons
beyond
this is at the northern part of the site
again you can see there's some fly
ticking
and various hard standings
again now just a few photos within the
buildings
just to sort of confirm their very poor
state of
um poor condition they're in at the
moment which
not only imposes sort of a
from an aesthetic point of view it isn't
great for the
town but also from a health and safety
point of view there are significant
issues
lots of graffiti so they are being
frequented
this is the view down limers hill
immediately
on the right just below the copper beach
tree is the high bridge house site which
is the german county council land
that's the redundant building you can
see it's just very overgrown it's very
sort of scrub
this is the bridal way
this is the very end of the application
site in terms of railroad
the existing commercial operation is
immediately
in front here um i have got some further
slides on that further down just in
terms of the nature of that operation
and then roll road continues just on the
right hand screen there the southwest
water site is just
begins over that the other side of the
hedge on the right
this is royal road itself as it
continues along
the southwest water boundary
this is the very end of the southwest
water site and
railroad itself then narrows down to a
much much um
much narrower path
so this is um field one the the eastern
field
the southwest water sites
central field
very western field
it's just moving through the proposals
now the layout plans
this is the comprehensive master plan
for the whole site
um with the exception of the southwest
water site which is very sort of north
western
section all of the other dwellings are
before you in detail for consideration
and the small
section to the northeast doesn't form
part of your consideration today but
there's already
detailed commission for 13 dwellings so
it's 173 dwellings in total
the public open space as you can see
will be focused
all down within two hectares of land and
south the site
planting the river this open space will
include two equipped play areas each
being 300 square meters
um there is also indicatively shown 1.5
hectares of allotment space in the very
northwest
tip of the southwest water site um
[Music]
and you can see there's three points of
access here so you have
where the red main red line is that's
the main access in
through the site even through the
further access into the car park
associated with the retail
an apartment block and then a third of
vehicular access right to the south and
just
um just before town bridge
just looking at a bit more detail at the
layout for a 4526 of 2020 which is
um toyota valve site so this is made in
full
19 dwellings which take a linear
approach along the very south of royal
road
it's a mix of detached and semi-detached
dwellings with 16 two beds three three
beds
there's a new length of highway that
comes in immediately to the north of
those properties
and that is distinctly separate from
roll road itself and there is a
landscaped
area that will run through through the
center
the the new highway will serve these
residential properties
but will also serve the commercial
premises that are in the
top right hand corner top left hand
corner
back of that screen the open space is
is pretty much solely provided for the
whole master plan but within this
application site
um in total there's about two hectares
there's also
the bat house um to be converted
which is at the very eastern corner of
the open space
the um the levels need to be reprofiled
so that
everything works in terms of the the
wider master plan and this
this involves raising railroads by 1.3
to 1.5 meters so it's
it's it's position is still the same
it's just it's just
going to be made higher so everything
works
this is the reserve mata site so
pursuant to the hybrid commission
71 dwellings are coming forward on this
site
and these are a mix of so there's 14 one
beds within the apartment block
there's 26 two beds 31 three beds
predominantly two-story aside from the
retail
apartment building and there are four
retail units that will come forward at
the ground floor level
of that apartment blog um
there's no employment uses proposed on
this site as you'll see in your agenda
reports
and justification and employment land
demand letter has been provided to show
there isn't
a demand for employment on this site
um there is also the viability position
to factor in as well
um
you can see um
[Music]
that there are seven dwellings within to
the south of railway that are within
this reserve matters
site you've also got the very bottom
southeast corner
the there's an area part of the open
space obviously this is where surface
water drainage tank will be located
within that graded banked area
interestingly there's also the car
parking within
um within this site that
is actually part of um
that lengths sorry the retail units
they the apartments have their own
parking as you can see directly from
weimar's hill
but the parking for the retail units
actually forms part of
different sites for the application we
just looked at so
again emphasizing the need for a
comprehensive link to approach
this is a hybrid house so the devon
county council site
this is 18 dwellings in full they're all
over two stories
um predominantly semi-detached on this
part of the site
five two beds thirteen three beds um
accessed through the reserve matters
site
the pink and blue highlights on here
show
different elevational materials so the
the dwelling could be a mix of brick and
render referencing
the current buildings on site
and this is just showing how that will
be spread throughout the sites to add
some architectural distinction between
properties
and so you'll get that balance of quick
facing and rendered properties
these red arrows just show permeability
particularly pedestrian permeability
through
and around the site so there are links
down to the public open space
up across to the 19 unit sorry the 13
units that are
have permission in full and across out
to the southwest water site
this shows indicatively southwest water
layout all matters are reserved so there
aren't any matters of detail before you
in terms of the southwest water site
however indicatively we can see 52
dwellings
and there is 0.5 hectares of open space
right up in the top corner
which would be the allotment
requirements so the allotment
requirements for the master plan will be
secured within this site again access
comes through
through the main reserve matters site
just running through some street
sections now
um through with all of these sections i
would encourage members just to to
understand
how visually the change in work and
random materials look
and also that there is a bit of
architectural distinction in terms of
orientation of the roof we see there's
some gable ends
um fronting roads and paths
um just add some architectural
distinction so this is from roll road
and new
highway looking south
this is from the public open space so
down by the river looking up towards
the north so you can see a number of the
dwellings have sort of a depth raised
area
um due to flood risk mainly that's been
designed in
for that basis we've also got graded
banks
um conditions are recommended to secure
detailed landscaping schemes and that
will be important to make sure
aesthetically that that
works in the context of the open space
but equally ensures
appropriate privacy for for the various
properties
so the top two are sort of roads that
cut through the center of the site
um the cross section at the bottom shows
the public open space right down at the
end
and getting the different orientations
of the dwellings
again these hopefully show sections that
show how the levels work
you'll see certainly quite clearly in
the central section
the right hand property is over a split
level so the properties along the
northern part of the master plan
do have to incorporate a split level
design to work with that
changing gradient um but architecturally
that's considered acceptable
again these are sections looking towards
the east
seeing the bottom section you can see um
in the middle
roll road and the public highway the
landscaping in between
and then the dwellings would be to the
south
and then the open space below so just
showing
showing how that works
this is very much within the center of
the site for main road coming in and
showing
the link up towards the high bridge
house site and how there is that
changing level with the
properties beyond and the very northern
properties as shown just outlines there
so to appreciate that change in height
and gradient
so just run through some of the
elevations now these are
semi-detached
again these are also in that same
location but
um brick facing it's like different the
gable ends
and again these are within the center of
the site
they just want to highlight certainly on
the front and rear elevations the window
treatments you can see there's
larger windows and the nature of those
window panes it's picking up on that
existing architectural style within
within the creamery site
again these are these are dwellings that
will be within that that sort of
sentinel central section to the
minister's railroad
and again showing the brick frontier
detached dwelling
further semi-detached dwelling again
utilizing the decking
again noticing that changing levels and
also that fenestration those window
details and
and this is about how the the structure
that's going to be converted from the
back house and we'll see there is
quite a significant below ground element
works that have to be down to cater for
those mitigation needs
okay so this is the retail and apartment
block
um this has been designed as a statement
building to reference that historic
context that's picking up on the
the brick and the rendering the window
details of the
existing buildings that i showed you
photos of earlier
um it will take the appearance of a
two-story dwelling from lima sails to
that top
image three stories working with the
levels from railroad itself
residential on the the upper floors the
retail units would be at ground floor
level with that direct access onto
railroad
and so there is that connection with
with the public open space royal road
and it also has that visible presence
two date stones from the current site
are to be retained and put
within the southern elevation so there
they are annotated there and that will
be conditioned that they are put in
place before the building comes into use
the four retail units there's a larger
unit of
more than 200 square meters and then
three much smaller units
and this is consistent with the the
hybrid permission
which specifically says in the
description 200 square meters of retail
um however as stated in the report there
is now a wider e
use class which covers various things
including cafes restaurants
retail day centers crashes
surgeries financial professional
services
gymnasiums indoor recreation all manner
of things so there would be flexibility
with the use of those
of those retail units um it's important
to highlight there have been some
letters of representation
and letters of objection received
specifically in relation to
this this building um from
the listed buildings so in that central
image you can see the three-story
um building to the rear to the roof
comes up to just the mid
middle of that second story window you
can just make out the chimneys of the
adjoining cottage
so these buildings are listed um
and the objections received raised
raised to
concerns really the impact on molested
buildings of heritage impacts
but also the amenity impact from the
proximity of this new building
to those dwellings um we did have
further late representation from one of
the objectives yesterday
um however in discussion there's no new
issues that have been raised and
all of the objections are summarized in
your in your um
report so just to sort of give give some
background to this firstly on the
amenity
side of things um i'm sure members will
be aware with new
new retail new housing developments we
often try to secure
window to window distances at the floor
of 21 meters it's a rule of thumb it's
not setting policy
but it's it's good practice in terms of
that
that level of distance you need to
ensure that people aren't directly
looking into each other's windows
this distance further to amendment to
our request is 12 meters
so the windows that would look straight
to the dwellings are the top image
so the left-hand side of that top
building
um ground floor level as you can see the
people walking along we don't have such
issue with you would
you would ordinarily expect people to be
walking along the pavement potentially
looking into
your windows it is that thirsty level
that we have her concern with and we've
worked with the architect to
to get some amendments so the windows
have been changed on that elevation
the rendered elevation to the side
that's set much further back so there
isn't a concern with that
um so what you have is the labeled
window there it serves a kitchen
and this is proposed for that to be
obscure glaze that's a main
living accommodation room and
to allow light to come in it will be
retained but there is a condition
clearly requiring that to be obscure
blade
to prevent that direct window to window
looking
the window to the left of the three page
that is a bedroom window
so there is less concern over that
daytime
looking between windows we didn't want
to go any further in terms of reducing
windows because architecturally
it would really lose that impact of that
building
and on balance it's considered that from
any window to window
impact now that the impacts are not so
significant
to justify receival i think it's also
important to note that surrounding
context as highlighted in the virtual
site visit that
integrity on the other side sorry
on the other side of the river you have
um
very intimate relationships between the
dwellings on either side of the road and
distances as
short as nine meters between between
window to window so
there is that surrounding context as
well um
it's not considered that there is um a
loss of light
to those properties or an overbearing
impact
of the road and all the activity that
goes with it there's also
it's important to bear in mind there is
that existing relationship will be it
the building becomes smaller but more
directly in front of the dwellings
um so in amenity terms it's considered
it's considered acceptable there there
clearly would be
another view from those mondays however
as you all know that's that's not a
planning consideration
just dealing with the heritage side of
things so the fact that they are listed
buildings and we have a duty to consider
the impact
the um the conservation officer is
raising no objection
she's provided some very detailed
comments and she's very much looked at
that
historic context of these listed
buildings and the relationship they've
always held
with the wider creamery site and
historic buildings that were on site
and there is a historic impact
assessment that
similarly concludes there will be a very
negligible impact on those listed
buildings
so there are just a couple more images
that hopefully hope to sort of help to
demonstrate that
so this section shows the distance
between the buildings and just the sort
of scale and massing
of that relationship the red line shows
what was originally
proposed so it has been called back as
far as it possibly can be
to achieve that accommodation the the
large windows you can see in the top
image
they actually serve um the left-hand one
serves the first four window
serves the same room where the obscure
glazed window would be so there will
still be a lot of light coming into that
room
again just running through the floor
plans you can see that that relationship
to the dwellings and limeless hill and
there would be some planting
immediately to the north of the retail
and apartment building which will
help soften that impact in that
relationship
that's showing the apartment again
apartments you can see the level whether
the cars will come in that's parking
specifically for the
wheat the residential units and then the
ground floor
shows how the retail units would work as
well
they would be serviced both in terms of
parking and deliveries
on the other side of railroad
it's just a historic photo the
conservation officer included in her
response
so the list of buildings are on the left
hand side you can see the
hip roof of the three-story building in
the cottage next to it
you can see historically there has
always been that that close relationship
between the creamery
and those listed properties
and again just showing these from the
south that
there has always always been that
context there so from a
heritage impact point of view it's not
considered that
there is harm
this just shows the outline master plan
so albeit this was indicative
the the intent has always been for the
retail
commercial element to be on that corner
um the master plan itself
succeeds because of it being in that
location
those retail units have the best
opportunity retail commercial units to
to achieve the best football and and to
serve wider needs than just the
development of being in that location
in terms of landscaping all of the
applications before you are subject to
detailed landscaping conditions so the
full applications
recommendations for detailed landscaping
to the two full applications
the reserve matters application whilst
it's um landscaping is the consideration
there is a condition on the hybrid
commission
um so what's before you is is still
slightly indicative and the conditions
are worded accordingly we would want to
see a very detailed proposal coming
through to discharge conditions
including planting specifications
timing of planting and this just shows
that
so the open space within the toyota
valve application
you can see the indicative areas for the
play areas which would have a direct
pedestrian linked through
linking one to royal road the detail of
those players would be secured through
an open space scheme via the section 106
and that will very clearly stipulate the
need for
certain numbers of player equipment and
also
given the flood zone the need for that
play equipment to be designed
appropriately to be robust in terms of
flooding
um you see the trees are to be retained
along the river additional planting
through that
that landscape buffer between the new
highway and railroad
that's just the other end there again
through discharge and condition will be
very keen to secure a quality
landscaping scheme
certainly for the the banks area and
also those rear boundaries
of those dwellings as well so it'd be
important to make sure that that works
for everybody we'll be using that space
this is the um ventral bit of the sights
of the reserve masters and high bridge
house
showing the introduction of hedgerows
new trees will be planted
but importantly that northern and
eastern boundary will be retained in
terms of the existing trees
and the conditions recommended to
prevent any further
points of access coming out onto either
of those roads
um the the designing our prime officer
did raise some concerns over the
pedestrian link the very north
that would connect through to the 13
units beyond
potential crime and disorder concerns um
a balance really does have to be struck
here because of the levels because of
the need to connect into the 13 units
beyond
and the condition is recommended to get
a detailed
design and scheme to to reduce
the potential for antisocial behaviour
there
this is just indicative for the
southwest water site there are a series
of mature trees along that northern
boundary
the application is supported by a tree
um
tree protection plan and tree survey and
this indicative layout can succeed
whilst
retaining most of those quality
maturities
of course that will be looked at in
detail at further stage
this indicative layout does show a
grading of the land down to wall road
and pedestrian link down at all matters
are
reserved including access we would be
looking at the detail of that at the
next stage
um but i would emphasize that given that
very green boundary that you have at the
moment along railroad
the detail of that will be will be very
important there's no reason why we can
secure some planting
along there one rather than just a harsh
plant but that is very much for the
matter stage
again that's just the other portion you
can see that they are
indicatively showing the retention of
those hedgerow boundaries into three
or three fields
just showing a section and a plan of
roll road because i know that's that's
certainly
for members of the community of the town
council a very important
aspect of the scheme so that's sort of a
slightly
buff beige color that is roll road it
should be resurfaced with landscaping on
either side
so i think if you compare that to the
photos
you saw earlier in the presentation with
the redundant buildings either side of
that character of that experience of
walking through there
and it is well used will change
considerably
and your offices view for the better but
that landscaping treatment will be
important to keep that separate to the
to the highway beyond
i mean you've got the section at the
bottom that that shows
how how that could all sort of exist
and i just wanted to finally just sort
of
highlight this retained commercial unit
so i've just marked it in in red
um the the owner operator of this is lj
developments
and it's still operational this site um
they themselves have um
their the usage of the site is the
haulage ground
works there's a lorry maintenance
workshop but that's just for their own
vehicles
and typically there are 17 lorries 30
vans on site and
coming and going all associated with
their own operations
the maintenance workshop is just daytime
hours there is 24 access to the site
um but the noise survey that we've
received indicated no activity beyond
certainly beyond 9 pm with most things
in the yard mission by 7 30
there are two weather contracts out so
two parts of the site are occupied by
others
um but again this mainly involves
storage of vehicles
loading tipping storage of aggregates
jet washing etcetera
and results in this roughly additional
15 vehicle movements so
i know that was something that came out
of the slide visit just looking to get a
greater understanding of that commercial
operation
um it actually holds a strong
relationship probably the southwest
water site and then that very end
property on the reserve matters scheme
next slide and that just shows the
aerial photo so you can just appreciate
that
a lot of that activity takes place in
the open in that yard
and that's just showing you
an image of the site so you can
appreciate what it's what it's what it's
like
this is an extract from the noise survey
so
you've got the southwest water buildings
plotted on there
the larger building which is within the
sites there's some workshop
the yard extends out so you can see the
the darker the color the noisy and the
activity that the noisiest activities
are very much within young artists
within the open um
the noise assessment was requested by
the environmental protection officer
mainly to consider the impact on the
southwest water site and the conditions
recommended
for a mitigation scheme in terms of the
dwelling
that's before you for approval today
which is the very sort of southern
such to the southeast there are no
windows in that end elevation
you'll see this end of the site there is
less activity
going on so um the officers are
satisfied
that the design of that dwelling and
given the nature of that commercial use
that that's appropriate and won't give
rounds to immensely harm
in terms of day-to-day movements from
that site um
that is not got an mot presence so it is
the only movements
don't relate to the that site you don't
have visiting
customers as such um the noise
assessment concludes that
vehicle movements are known that and
actually insignificant when you compare
them to
the b327 and the a386 that's slightly
further away
just finally just to show a plan of the
highway adoption layout so
the routes in are sort of shady and grey
you have
the main road coming through off the
bend the outer end of
lima's hill and then the new route
further to the south which will serve
the commercial unit i was just
describing
and these points of access have already
been approved by the hybrid commission
the access into the flats is directly
from lyman's hill and the condition is
recommended to secure appropriate
visibility there are no objections from
the whole officer
and then this just shows the drainage
connections there were objections raised
from both seven flood risk and the
environment agency
so the surface water drainage strategy
had to be
had to be reconsidered and the original
proposed surface water pond which was
down in flood zone 3 and very close to
the river torridge
has been removed and it's now a tanked
underground system which you can just
see at that bottom
that porcelain ends there there's a
slightly lighter blue
which will be concealed within within
the bank
um both statute consultants are raising
new objections now
in terms of flooding and surface water
so that that's the comprehensive
presentation
um i think if i just sort of summarize
the main planning considerations
for that comprehensive approach um so in
terms of the principle of development
and land uses the wider site is
allocated most of it's allocated under
policy gtt01
in terms of land uses no employment is
now proposed however that's been
justified by the viability appraisal
and the employment land demand letter
there is however retail uses retained
um and the nature of that use
could now be consumed quite flexibly
under the new used class e
there is strategic open space which is a
requirement of the policy which will go
beyond the needs of the development
there's no built form outside of the
development boundary either so i think
it's important to note that
in terms of design and layout um
the the design has been brought forward
with reference to that existing context
which is
good design principles to follow so both
in terms of materials and
fenestration but also the the retail and
apartment building will
have date stones to reference the
creamery as well
so the design and layout is considered
to be a high quality
and um appropriate for the site in terms
of impact and landscape the
landscape visual impact assessment
includes a positive impact
the the large buildings that currently
redundant and the light source will be
removed
and replaced with predominantly
two-story dwellings with the exception
of the three-story element of the
retail block so there's a significant
positive in terms of impact on the
landscape
impact on the heritage um i focused in
on the impact
on the listed buildings joining the
proposed retail and apartment building
and consistent with the heritage impact
assessment conclusions and the
conservation of
comments there's not considered to be
harm in terms of heritage
the architectural office sort of
archaeology officer democratic council
is recommending conditions to ensure
written schemes of investigation were
followed at the site in terms of
archaeology
amenity the site the new build element
is laid out appropriately with
appropriate distances and
window-to-window relationships and
orientation
the the relationship of the existing
listed buildings with with the new
apartment block i went to
some detail on that that's not
considered to give rise to
significant amenity harm so it's
justified refusal
and indeed there are conditions that can
deal with any
noise concerns from that retained
commercial unit
highways much of the access
considerations
and traffic generation etcetera were
considered
as part of the hybrid commission so
there's no objections in terms of
highways there are concerns over
from third parties and local groups over
the lack of any contributions wider
cycling provision
however as you'll see from the viability
position that is not the
the surplus section 106 money is to do
that
drainage we now have satisfactory flood
risk
surface water scheme the sequential
tests had to be applied because of
residential being proposed with
influenza
iii um and both the sequential tests and
the exceptions tests are both considered
to have been passed as detailed
as detailed in the report contamination
the reserve matters fight is um coming
forward pursuant to a number of
conditions already on that hybrid
permission
so there's already conditions that have
been discarded discharged to secure
method statements for asbestos removal
demolition
contamination the environmental
protection officer is recommending the
full contamination condition and
asbestos conditions for the two full
applications
and the contamination conditions for the
southwest water site so
there are conditions in place to ensure
that the site is
is developed safely and appropriately
with regard to contamination
apology there are a series of ecology
reports
however the most recent comprehensive
approach
taken has been supported by an
overarching ecology report in terms of
the
reserve matters site and two full
applications uh
a net gain in excess of 10 can be
secured
and the southwest water side give me
outline nature
that we don't have a confirmed drainage
scheme um
or landscaping that is indicatively
being
shown as potentially a minor loss in net
gain overall
across the whole site um as set out in
your committee report
it is very much hoped that through the
reserve matters of the southwest water
site we can ensure that there is no
net gain that as we're directed to do
and and we're confident that that can be
achieved but that can't be confirmed at
this stage
sometimes without lines we secure an
offsite contribution the viability we
have at the moment there isn't that
scope to do that
and we also if you were to leave enough
site area to provide
new habitat a significant amount of the
site would not be able to be developed
which again are not going to be
the viability so we're very keen and
confident to secure the best outcome
there at reserve matters stage
i think it's also important to note
there are a significant number of
mitigation measures in terms of
um bird boxes b bricks
hedgehog houses which don't factor into
that overall calculation
and also the new hedgerows don't factor
in so there is a
wider ecological benefit at the site
liability in section 106 obligations so
that the
the reserve matters scheme has already
been considered a
outline stage and that was deemed
unviable
so the reserve matters we are where we
are in terms of that not being viable
that hybrid permission secured no
affordable and no off-site contributions
bringing in now this comprehensive
approach which has reassessed the whole
site the whole 173 units
it does show that there is a deliverable
scheme although there is no
ability to secure any affordable housing
or any contributions towards
education or um off-site built
facilities all of the open spaces to be
on site
at more open spaces required would be
on-site
um and similarly at the hybrid stage and
devon county council were trying to seek
a contribution towards cycle
improvements and at that stage it was
concluded that it wasn't viable to do
that so the proposal before you
um does not include any affordable
housing or off-site contributions
um to meet the needs of the development
so um finally in terms of the
comprehensive plan balance
which is all set out in detail in your
report but the the significant benefits
of this scheme
um most notably are the redevelopment of
what is currently uh
an eyesore in the landscape significant
health and safety issues
um it's a site that has been redundant
derelict for 20 years
this comprehensive approach looks to be
achieving a deliverable scheme which
the redevelopment of the site removal of
those buildings is
is a really significant positive
and linked with that the the positive
impact on the landscape
given our five-year land supply context
the delivery of housing will be without
any affordable
is also a significant benefit this
scheme there are also further benefits
in terms of the strategic open space
which will serve
needs beyond beyond the development
um the enhancements to roll road itself
as well
so that sort of landscape setting is
also a significant benefit
many of the impacts are neutral i.e with
mitigation and design
there's no objections from statutory
conservatives
to balance against the positives the
harm identified is
most significantly the lack of liability
to the fact that you will be having
173 new units in this location
without the ability to provide any
affordable or any contributions towards
primary education most notably
which which is a negative prosperous
scheme there is some
very limited harm in terms of the impact
of that retail
the retail apartment block but not so
great to justify refusal
so in terms of the comprehensive
proposal the officer recommendation is
that all four of the individual
applications are approved
the reasons set out within the
individual reports but that it's it's
essential that a comprehensive legal
agreement
is secured for all four that ties them
all together
um to ensure phasing of demolition
site clearance delivery of
infrastructure because
there's bits of infrastructure across
each of the individual sites
within that as well and the applicant
has agreed to this
um and this is further advice from the
district valuer
there there should be review mechanisms
for viability
um with the first one of those being
once the site's been cleared
so if there is any scope to realize in
section 106 monies we should be
monitoring that throughout
and the section 106 will also secure the
public open space
so on balance it's considered the
significant benefit of redeveloping this
site
outweighs the harm that's being
identified
well thank you very much
very very comprehensive presentation
and i think the the overview and
doing it in this way is overview because
of course
the crucial aspect of this is linking
them all together
and the overall linkage of these four
sites
and so if members are happy we'll
discuss it and
indicate the comprehensive view
and if there are any specifics from any
of the individual applications
special then meltdown
[Music]
so if anybody wants to take five minutes
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
right
actually comes through
[Music]
[Music]
oh
all right thank you thank you everybody
for getting back in this faces um
and our first speaker then this morning
is
councillor doug smith it's going to turn
to town council
[Music]
that's not the table in the microsoft
their same thing
while we're looking at four applications
i think you probably
realize we're considering the overall
complete scheme so
i'm only asking everybody to speak once
yes
and if there's any particular issues
from any of the individual applications
right
thank you very much thank you i'll be
leaving with the three minutes
rather than keep coming up and down
freezing
um thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak on behalf of great
tournament council
um i think a lot of what helen
brought up in her presentation is is
going to be covered by our thoughts and
you've seen my representation from the
planning
uh the planning committee act at
torrington um
as part of the list of documents that
you've got in front of you um there's
one
from uh great tourism town council dated
march 17th
2021 um i don't propose to read this out
to you you'll be pleased to hear
uh but i would commend its contents to
the to the committee
in essence it addresses the four
applications before the committee
today and it is treating them with a
degree of commonality
it recommends that initially no
developments be commenced until the site
has been cleared
and any contamination removed
the level of liability of affordable
housing demanded by development on this
scale
be reassessed throughout the demolition
and construction
support of local employment
opportunities i think is
quite a critical one and consideration
should be given
to live uh those voice units i know we
haven't got those but
it's the local employment opportunities
i think we were keen to stress
um the views of the commons
conservatives must be considered
and the area is environmentally
important
and part of future developments of local
amenities for tourist industries
i know we've looked into the um the
green issues and
that's all being taken into account
um dcc highway satisfaction all parts of
the site and impact on existing users
online
as well i think this is quite critical
it's a busy road anyway
and obviously there will be an increase
in track upon that
mill street already um has got new
signage
uh underway we've been in discussion
with uh dcc for quite some time and
we're reviewing and reviewing
all the signage around and we're trying
[Music]
and especially for um emergency vehicles
we've had a number of
times when ambulances and foreigners
have not really been able to attend
easily
so that's something that we must look at
and we're actually asking
that hgvs must be
re-rooted and this
for some in some way has to be enforced
now unfortunately there's always a
problem i realize that
but during the construction phase
particularly we're looking at an access
only restriction
on on mill street um and
possibly in the longer term but that's
that's a different issue really
um the location and size of the
recreation area is also
slight cause for concern um we're not
entirely convinced that they're
big enough and
that's maybe something we can we can
bear in mind
um the active travel plan is being
addressed by
another speaker shortly so i won't
really go into that but i have to say
i've looked at that and you know very
much in agreement
that was not some part of it was really
not realistic unless you're a
yellow jersey cyclist in the north pole
france then you might be able to
keep up with some of the recommendations
on that plan but i i thought
can you speak up because we've been
drowned out i'm so sorry
i'll come i'll come back i'll come a
little bit closer
um and really what was once the pride of
the town
the history of employment um for many
the site has
become a thorn in the in the flesh and
is often referred to
as a chernobyl i mean that word has been
used many many times
sadly the buildings are long past saving
as we all
know and really have become a magnet for
intruders seeking excitement
and this has led to several fatalities
over the years which is this trend
the emergency services have also been
deployed many times at considerable cost
to the community
and it also takes them away from the
ability to
respond to more pressing
um firsthand i've witnessed them one
evening for example in excess of ten
police vehicles
three ambulances two fire appliances
including the turntable from barnstable
which we don't have one locally had to
come out from there
um and even the force helicopter on more
than one occasion
so any anyone with any idea of
finance and i'm sure we all have that uh
it's a bit of a nightmare
um over several years i've
been instigating numerous meetings with
interested parties in the hope of trying
to bring this sad chapter in the light
of the dairy to a close
and i know that tdc has taken is as keen
as anyone
to relegate this entire episode to
history
uh on behalf of great torrington town
council i do urge
acceptance of all four applications
thank you thank you councilman thank you
uh our next uh public contributed to
speak against the applications is
davey job
good morning good morning and
again as i said to the previous speaking
if you've got to address this is a
comprehensive application indeed
um and you've got three minutes but i'm
being kept
it's just four applications
thank you thank you for the opportunity
to um
i should put that a bit closer is that
better
okay i'll get as close as possible to
this microphone
um i'm speaking um in my capacity
as a lifelong cyclist but also
as one of the founder members of the
northern devon
cycling campaign um
my main contention is that in the
absence
of an active travel plan which um
council adams alluded to i do fear
that this development will result in
substantial increases in road traffic
and that will be to the detriment of
vulnerable road users um the torrington
environment more widely and also i
believe our endeavors to
mitigate climate change i would like to
refer
initially to one of the policy
statements
referenced by the planning officer and
this comes from
the great touring to neighborhood plan
uh paragraph t2
states that all major development shall
make adequate
sorry adequate on-site and off-site
provision
for pedestrians and cyclists creating
or contributing to the creation of
safe and attractive walking and cycling
routes
by enhancing existing or creating new
paths
particularly to the town centre
to main employment centers and to
the schools and i think we need to ask
ourselves
do these applications meet
those criteria and those those
aspirations and i think
my conclusion has to be the answer
is no because instead of
an active travel plan we have
a transport assessment
which is attached to the applications a
fairly
substantial document um which you may
or may not have had time to actually
delve through i suspect
um but there are two contentions
in this transport assessment which i do
confess
i find really quite um problematic
the first is that um
the first contention in the report is
that new residents
will have easy access to the town centre
on foot or by cycle enabling them to
reduce their car dependency
and to support that there is quite a lot
of quantitative data
in the report but most particularly
there is a table um which
estimates travel times on foot and by
cycle
from the development site
to a number of locations in the town
centre
so if i could just take some examples
from that um
torrington town centre by cycles is
3.5 minutes littles
2.1 minutes um torrington dental
practice
2.8 minutes um i think you can probably
gather quite readily that these are the
times of
yellow jerseys and and tour de france
and certainly not something that an
aging
cyclist like myself could could readily
accomplish um i think i can see how this
how this misleading information has
arisen
um i suspect that the data was put
together
probably as a desktop study um
probably using google maps which you
know doesn't have any contours on it
and so no account has been taken of the
approximately um 300 foot
elevation gain between teleport
and and torrington and torrington center
um the second contention which i have
difficulty with
is that it's assumed
that these journeys to the town center
and
and other facilities perhaps to the east
can be accomplished um safely
and i'll just briefly pick out a
paragraph
sorry pick out a paragraph from the
report
which i would like to question
one paragraph states that the pedestrian
cycle routes to the town
and local facilities do not require
any crossing or busy roads or any travel
along busy roads with most routes being
lightly trafficked
or traffic free even the limited
sections of walking or cycling
along or across the a386
are not affected by high levels of
traffic
or high proportions of hgb traffic
i i find that astonishing in view of the
fact that
several of the routes that are involved
in this
would entail
negotiating new street and car street
which as we know
and i'm sure anyone who's attempted to
cycle in torrington will know
is an extremely hostile
environment for any vulnerable
road user and the
report also analyzes
rta data road traffic accident data over
the last
five years for torrington and
uses that information to try and
indicate that
origin streets are pretty safe for all
and sundry
what they identify
yes what they identify is one serious
injury
in an rta over five years and
what they fail to point out is that that
accident actually involved a cyclist
cycling along new street with
right-of-way being hit by a car coming
out of white's lane
and that individual is still house bound
four years on
from that rta so in summary
i do fear that without an active travel
plan
this development will entail a very high
level of car dependency
for local journeys to the detriment of
our carbon footprint air quality
congestion in current streets and the
safety of
vulnerable road users thank you thank
you very much thank you
[Music]
thank you our final speaker this morning
is john lethbridge in support
i believe
thank you and same thing applies i'm
being a bit
flexible with the three minutes thank
you because
you're addressing the four applications
and talking of course
good morning members i'm dan lethbridge
from ala architecture and we're the
architects for the four applications
that make up the overall master plan
development before you today
i just want to talk to you really
quickly about some of the overall
benefits associated with the delivery of
this master plan
always uh discussed the dangerous
brownfields site
the existing site has been subject to
development discussions for over 20
years
and as you've heard is allocated within
the local plan we fully understand the
design within the community to see these
large
dangerous buildings taken down and the
master plan before you today can finally
offer a real opportunity to replace
these structures and abandon
hardstanding yards with an attractive
mixture
developer and wind wide-ranging public
open space
and ecological improvements whilst the
existing sites that comprise the overall
master plan area
feature head roads and trees along the
boundaries and the degree of scrubling
a substantial portion of the overall
land area comprises the former
industrial buildings
hard standings and pasture grazing
all of which with fairly limited
biodiversity potential
the ecology reports that accompany the
application include recommendations for
improving biodiversity throughout the
site
through considered use of landscaping
and open space treatment as well as
built in habitat boxes for birds bees
and bats existing hedgerows are retained
wherever possible
and new hedge banks are proposed
throughout the development to break down
the scale of the street streets street
scenes
with green corridors for wildlife the
creation of new riverside open
space offers a further opportunity for
substantial ecology gains of the correct
landscaping treatment accounting
specification and ongoing management
raw road has been identified as an
important part of the public realm in
this area
both in the original hybrid application
on the creamery site
and within the current proposals in
front of you
the existing router on roll road is
lined with derelict buildings and
industrial uses
and heavy goods traffic does use the
shared surface concrete
routes along that way making it a
dangerous place for pedestrians
seeing that firsthand myself the master
plan before you today proposes a number
of improvements to royal road
to create an attractive and safe route
for pedestrians and cyclists that will
be
dedicated away from traffic beyond the
improvements to roll road
the mass plan includes the creation of
over two hectares of riverside public
open space
in addition to some community allotments
the public open space will include
formal play areas you've heard
as well as large areas of informal open
green space for walking play and simply
enjoying the outdoors
as large areas of riverside frontage
will now be opened up
and made much more accessible for public
use and habitat creation
as well as achieving the required
emission targets in use as part of
building regulations
the dwellings have all been designed to
be efficiently constructed
a combination of potentially used prefab
elements
fairly simple forms and everything in a
bad way
maximizes material efficiency and we
hope that would reduce the potential for
sideways so as well as looking at
energy efficiency in use we hope that
that can help with the sort of low
carbon development agenda
in conclusion the application before you
today offer a deliverable
sustainable development on a very
technically challenging site
as well as delivering a broad mix of one
two three and four bedroom homes uh the
four bedrooms
on the southwest water site indicatively
at the moment uh the master plan
proposals will provide a wide range of
public realm improvements
on this important riverside location we
would ask therefore that you follow
officer recommendations
and approve these applications thanks
very much
and finally there's a statement from
is
uh so this is a statement from
councillor tottenham
i am able to attend on friday but please
could this be read out by an officer in
relation to the old clean reactions
my apologies for not being there in
person and thank you for reading this
out
i will be clear into your point the old
creamery has been an eyesore for as long
as i can remember
it being direct is all i have ever known
and something needs to be done
the site attracts attracts trespassers
for various reasons
for decades it's been and continues to
be a serious danger
to people who are tempted inside as well
as putting lives at risk
it also puts a huge strain on our
emergency services who are called out
regularly
the council must be absolutely clear and
certain that any development of any of
the lands
related to or surrounding the euro
creamery can only take place
after full demolition and clear of the
site has taken place
this is absolutely non-negotiable and we
cannot risk any building works
taking place without this happening
first in terms of affordable housing
the applicant has said that none will be
viable on the site
i would ask that this is regularly
reviewed and must be provided if all
possible
affordable housing is much needed both
in great times and across the tourist
district
many thanks thanks sir
are you sure right that's the last of
the contributions
for the committee to discuss we'd like
to start councillor brown
20 plus
[Music]
the reason is i don't believe we need to
go through all this
pictures as we are going to get
my officer was excellent in addition to
the public's concerns
and we are mainly flooding downstream
clearance of the site um
which i think will be as the officers
say
legal agreement which will be included
in the three
board members boys and of course of the
last vessels there's a particles
as part of the construction plan that
may be
a huge conservative
homes we've seen from the district
vision
uh impossible but maybe in the future we
could be looked at today
we've heard from mr joe that there are
concerns for cyclists
and i would like to see how many people
could actually cycle
up you know
take a great man's chance so i think all
in all i'd like to propose
i know they have to be discussed
individually
but they could be voted on i believe as
a whole
right and i also think that we've got
their embraces
of all the conditions attached which um
thank you
[Music]
comprehensive statement
together covers all of them but we'll
have to go to
the vote in the beginning because they
are individual applications
and so you're proposing we do accept
those
all it was um i was very pleased to hear
that um
the 106 and the contributions
it's going to be reviewed as time goes
on um
report correctly the 5 minute report
i think it said a demolition cost of 1.2
million if i read that right which
yeah which obviously i can well believe
is the residual land values deemed to be
1.7 million
now i would have thought that 1.7
billion for derelict site has actually
brought a lot of money and i would have
thought that some of that demolition
cost would have come off that 1.7
million
value
[Music]
uh yes joe we have mr gill um from dbs
who was our independent assessor um who
i believe would be happy to take any
questions that they may have on the
viability element
um so if doctors do have any questions
and if you do have that opportunity
today
all right well i'll bring cancer
thank you yeah i'll make a general point
first that when this
application came before us last time
councillor langley the late
councillor langley and myself both urged
very strongly that the most important
thing is
and you've heard from the local
councillor
because i don't want any developer to
come along just cherry pick
the easy bits and then walk away
and i have suggested i will suggest now
that
i understand we can't do it at a
planning meeting because this will be a
legal agreement but i have
i will ask that the three times
encounters are involved
in that legal agreement so there is some
oversight of this
and the other thing i want to bring up
[Music]
is the district values report because as
you know for years i've asked that we
can see
these and finally we are seeing them and
they are absolutely fascinating because
this one
[Music]
where there's no section 106 and i can
understand that because it is
a very difficult site but
there's something that i'm really quite
upset about in this fabulous report
if you turn page 70 in our agenda 17
17 700
should we
uh marketing fees
829 000 pounds
and then you've got legal fees down
below agent sales fees 425
000 pounds that's that's one point
was one quarter million pounds for
marketing
160 houses which is what we've got today
do you think one point 140 million
pounds to market 160 houses
when i've talked to local surveyors and
i suspect all of us are aware
that houses are being sold off the
internet without anyone looking at them
i mean does it really is it really going
to cost that much if we're going to look
again
at these section 106 box i think we need
to look again at these
incredibly inflated marketing fees
they're just ridiculous and we have
those suggestions from the local council
yesterday that um is there any money for
a state board
and part of the open space could there
be money for a cycle track
well i think there is actually within
you start look at those marketing fees
and come down to the real world and i
think there is money there and i would
move that we actually put that in
as part of our uh mission
well during the break i did mention to
sean that i
had a discussion with a planning
government planning officers or
neighborhood planning offices
and people involved in
[Music]
viability appraisals a few days ago it
was an online meeting
and the the view was that we really
councils really must stop challenging
these viability
appraisals and i'm going to agree with
councillor christopher
through some of the figures in here you
know
600 legal fees 600 per market
one market some of these fees if you
shaved off a half a percent
on some of them there'd be a lot of
money available
for either affordable housing or
skateboard
fact that we all realize that this slide
is
is going to cross a lot to clear
there's a lot of contamination with this
side but so we all accept that
but into the scheme of that side now
that council board me
made the point as well about the land
value there is a bad
value there and a slight difference
and it's something that would will bear
in mind and
certainly i think we'll perhaps have a
separate meeting at some time to discuss
viability of president but we do make
sure we do challenge them
very strongly when we're getting
absolutely nothing out of the scheme
apart from a derelict site being
obviously substantially improved
if we do run these four applications
anybody else want to cancel a lot yeah
we're going back
i mean it's too late now isn't
[Music]
[Music]
mouse
i don't know
mr gill could i just ask you to come up
in general
on this um you've heard the comments you
don't have
just to make some comments on how
vigorously these are challenged it's not
just this one
today we've had several this committee
have where
we felt a bit more challenged should we
not just more or less seem like rubber
stamping
[Music]
i mean we have to objectively look at
the numbers
um and i appreciate your concerns about
the
figures in the appraisal particularly
allowances for marketing uh legal costs
of sales
that kind of thing all i could say on
that is that we
we these are industry standard figures
in this and they've been established
planning appeals
numerous planning appeals and we do look
at every
every element of any development
appraisal
that's submitted and challenge every
aspect of it
i appreciate your concerns about the
cost of the backed house that that was
my fault
um that was our our quantity surveyor
who who originally
uh looked at that um as he did
and look at the demolition questions on
the costume scheme and we have been
looking at this
now for about five or six years i think
since we did the original uh work on
development viability
and it has actually and the scheme was
desperately
undeliverable essentially that's like so
far underwater that it was you know it
was questionable about
whether it could be delivered at all
that has ameliorated over the last
five or six years and particularly more
recently with the way the market
has moved in terms of the
you know i appreciate your concerns over
the way
the way the market is just at the moment
in terms of
health healthy demand and you know the
apparent apparently you can
sell houses by showing beans
this is a this is a large development
which is going to happen over a number
of years
[Music]
looking at the previous
history and uh rather than just
well actually we'll strike out after
that because you can solve easily now
quite easily change which is where the
where we have the situations where there
is a
it's been for sure to be able to provide
all the
uh required contributions
we would always recommend the review
mechanisms included
[Music]
uh so that it can be revisited um and if
that's
an early stage it can possibly um
enable if the market conditions change
sufficiently
it can enable um some
[Music]
[Music]
um so are you saying that we can
actually revisit
section 106 after we've passed the
planning application
mechanism so we can use it viability
after a period of time
and this was very reason that we don't
have crystal ball we don't know what a
market is going to do
and that's actually beneficial could be
beneficial to us
it can also be beneficially happening of
course if the market goes the opposite
way
in certain instances so that's what the
review mechanism
mechanism for that review mechanism
is that written into every plan no
this one is something that we've
proposed for this particular application
that's absolutely fascinating thank you
i'll revisit that quite often i can say
the developers tend to be very very
resistant to the inclusion of review
mechanisms through various
i would argue serious but mainly
mainly it affects the bottom line but it
is a
it is an incremental thing so
[Music]
is available to contribute um to second
one and six
up to about the maximum obviously the
normal
policy required but it is it is it does
pretty suppose an increase
which they which is shared so you know
they're not going to go
down
[Music]
a comprehensive one would be an open
book review
where we would consider obviously any
sales prices that they've achieved for
units they've sold so far
any details of the actual costs they've
incurred
so we can we can examine um in an ideal
world with examining the full
accounts and development economics
at that stage as opposed to
at this stage where we're just we're
just looking at industry standard
assumptions
and built costs based on
our ics published rates
so it then becomes much more accurate
[Music]
thank you uh thank you for your
explanation very interesting
i'm sure you know the marketing cost is
something that is put forward for
actually selling the properties
irrespective of the sale price the sale
price is something
separate and this does seem rather high
as council christians pointed out to
sell this number of properties
um so surely
that should be looked at and i
appreciate it can't know but actually
looked at him in the first place because
um i saw the figure
it didn't really rebuild amongst all the
other things and someone's been pointing
out that it does seem extraordinary high
in respect for the same marketing
company will say well it's going to cost
us that much which does seem rather
ridiculous
so there's no way that can be reduced at
this stage i guess
no mainly because i mean if it if it
went to planning
we'd be on very very sticky wicket
essentially because
it has been sort of established over so
many years and it
includes state agencies and
show homes marketing costs related to
money
sharing and that sort of thing and it
it's
developers invariably first first
standards of housing speed will
invariably try and
ask for three percent which is usually
about one to one
one point two five one and a half
percent for a staging fees and then the
balance between marketing costs
and we have we have um
they quite often still do pass for three
percent but we
we
if you get a retirement scheme for
example um
they have because of the peculiarities
of those
and they actually are up around five
percent from
and that has been established in quite a
few years
quite hard against that i don't want to
drag this out too much and i do
appreciate mr gilmore being here this
morning
because this is really important for the
planet committee because
it's something that comes up time and
time again you keep mentioning the
industry standards but is that done on a
national basis because i can imagine
selling a house in a rundown park
liverpool it's going to be quite
difficult whereas selling one around
here is really easy
is it done on a national base is a
regional basis or a district basis or
what
it's it's done on a site-specific basis
so it is done on a regional
original basis but um the
generality of the allowances
tend to be informed by
um as i say the evidence base which can
be nationwide there's plenty of deals
i've seen
around the country and it is very
difficult to
[Music]
we would obviously seek to examine each
appeal and
certain particular circumstances in that
area um
before applying or applying them but
they it does
it does form an evidence base from which
is developed
um precedence in within the local area
[Music]
the district and the region so so if
that is done then
council hurley has just touched on this
at what point
did the planning committee get to
challenge this
with i'm told it can't be changed now
but this is the first time i've seen it
when it appears on my
agenda so at what point do counsellors
challenges
well well we we don't challenge it we
don't challenge it as campus council
um but when when a viability raises
before by a developer
and sean then hands that over
and the developer case to district
barrier or whoever
to check that viability
but we don't get to actually challenge
it until this teacher 106 within our
agenda today depends on this
and at what point do i get to challenge
it
very soon
so as we know the process we receive a
private assessment
from a developer as part of an
application
uh the council then instructed
independent review
um obviously this assessment in this
case happened through the dbs
was instructed uh which is actually the
cost covered by the applicant
council that independent review
will then discuss and negotiate the
applicant and confirm if they have an
agreement for that
assessment it could be the case that it
isn't and negotiations have taken place
once that's been completed it's then
presented to committee members
as part of the committee report as you
see today with a recommendation from
your officers
clearly if members felt as it was
reasonable
they could not agree that assessment or
they could defer the item
for further work to be done with
viability or even if there's evidence to
do so they could
make a decision contribute to your
office recommendation
clearly as your officers privileged
avoid extreme caution in that basis as
the matter has been independently
assessed
and clearly if we were to go to a appeal
situation
we have a virus assessment we've had it
independently assessed
and i'd be very cautious of our chance
of winning such an appeal
but that this is your opportunity now to
challenge that if you so wish
i'd say defend is a possibility if you
feel there's any particular element
that needed further investigation
however again i would say this has been
scrutinized independently
and the report has been put forward to
you by our officers
are what we feel is correct
professionally with the recommendation
of approval
yeah i would i would certainly caution
against that i think the review
mechanism
in section one and six is the way we
should go with this to build
that's that check and i'm gonna say that
i think we've got my breast at the
moment because you know this is in front
of us now
but i do find the whole item very
interesting can i propose that we asked
mr gill
to come to a separate meeting of the
plans committee to go
through all aspects of tv reports yeah
because what i think our discussion now
is development
committee council craigie thank you
and in respect to this particular
one do we have to specify we'd like to
review
when we would like the review or is it a
continuous assessment
how do we specify it's
it's slightly out of my realm of
expertise that's more of a question for
a lawyer
and in drafting section 106 agreement
but it it it's fairly flexible and
it's normally it's normally triggered at
a certain point so in this particular
case for example
um the site demolition and site
clearance
are big ticket items and they're going
to happen straight away
and there's made up ground and there's
that there's
uncertainty as to the extent of
additional piling
foundation works gonna be required and
that's those surveys can't
happen until the site is cleared so at
that point
because there are big costs involved in
that i am recommending the review takes
place once the site is cleared and the
survey of the information is available
and you can be more certain about the
costs
there's just any mitigation costs then
that could translate into
a contribution in section number six and
particularly there could be another
review mechanism after the same sale of
a certain number of units
and at the stage or stages during the
development of
where the bible is reviewed where we can
take into account
yeah so that discussion will be between
the solicitors on both sides
but if today as long as i think it's
already been moved
that the war members are involved with
that discussion
uh that would be part of that discussion
with all members
okay
[Music]
what i would suggest though is that not
here another one he actually looks at
the industry standard
for the figures that are provided in the
first place because they do seem
in this case pretty high i think he's a
town council
i mean a return on the
investment for the developers is between
15 and 20
this is at the higher end of about 18
and a half percent i think
that's so you know there is in there but
i don't
i don't go on any longer this morning
i'm pleased mr gill's been here i'm
pleased that
he has agreed at some place in the
future they'll have a particular
discussion
just on uh liability appraisals and
how they looked at and considered i'm
pleased now that in our
section 106 this morning we'll be able
to put in that we want this review
mechanism
mechanism and probably as mr gill's
alluded to it could be after
the site clear and some groundworks and
make
has been done and then maybe after the
first 50 developments have been
sold over 40 levels or whatever but that
could be put into the wrong section
and then we've got two two chances to
review how the cost of the development
in actual factors coming in because a
lot of it
is that when you when we've been looking
in the past
liability appraisals so i'm going to
draw the
interesting and very worthwhile
discussion on liability appraisals to an
end there
and thank you again mr gill for being
here and
as i said we want to put you on the spot
i'm pleased
[Music]
i'm going to just make my couple of
comments i've jotted down one thing
[Music]
[Music]
i noticed they've got these raised
balconies behind but they've also got
gardens behind
and they are above flooding level the
properties are and the bulk of
themselves the gardens obviously
could be prone to being flooded what i
would like to do is
how do anybody use any disability access
those regardless
from those properties
[Music]
yeah so there are conditions that have
been recommended by the environment
agency that requires
site levels to be confirmed prior to any
any construction of these specific
dwellings that's so that's something
we'll very much look at
through that process um in the hope that
you could have
sort of it would have to be outside
access
around and linking around to that rear
garden
you obviously wouldn't be able to unless
there was some sort of provision within
the driving itself that
um but yeah it is a necessary feature of
these dwellings because of them being
within flood zone three
and there's some very clear changes that
were specified by the environment agency
to
to allow for these dwellings to be
acceptable from a
flood risk technical point of view
um and these so these are the revised
joints that take account of that and so
you have
the optic white council ever got the
steps that drop
down there so that is something we can
look at through the discharging of that
specific condition
which is the purpose of that condition
is very much the environment agency and
the flood levels
but there'll be no reason why we can
look at that element within that
and and if you wanted we could even add
that as a matter to be considered within
that condition
if yeah you know does that mean
suggested
[Music]
yeah allow access all round yeah i mean
i think if the the relevant conditions
which relate to
0.526 and 0.528 um
be just amended very slightly that's the
standard voicemail so
it's a specific condition that's been
recommended by the environment agency we
can include
to look at that i mean i think what i
would say is that these
are a relatively small part of the
overall scheme
and the the design approach is is
very specific to that flood zone 3
location so it's not a usual
scenario so we would have to bear that
in mind but i would certainly agree if
we can do something to make them more
accessible we should be
thank you and when you were mentioning
the
obscure glazed windows in the apartment
and the distant building behind the
three-story list of buildings
yes um i didn't know
they of nothing isn't quite a higher
level than the
windows you know because of the obscure
clouds
but i think did you mention the distance
we built with
it's only 12 meters it is it is really
cool it is close
yeah so it's this element that projects
out on that north elevation at the top
so it's it's the two windows at first
floor level
there um you're absolutely right 12
meters is close
and we did look at this very carefully
with the architect um
but the purpose of the 21 meters is all
to do with
the ability to look between windows and
balance where we are satisfied that the
changes
so the obscure glazing to that small
kitchen window
however leaving the bedroom window
normal
and visible glass is on balance
acceptable in this scenario
there is a separate drawing which you
don't i suppose you can slightly tell
sections but not really in terms of the
the direct window to window positions as
well the architect did look at that in
the negotiations on the revisions to the
design
so the rhythm that direct window to
window element as well just because of
the nature of
the dwellings opposite but it is it is
certainly something that we've worked to
to better the scheme to get betterment
than what was originally improved but
yes it is it is close to 12 meters you
have to factor in
you have you have a main road in between
so it's not as if it's your garden
so that changes that that sort of
dynamic
and that wider context where you have
dwellings with windows within nine
meters of each other just down the road
so
yeah there is that grain of development
um so
all things contained which i really was
making is the fact that these two
movements at a higher level
yeah yes yes it is there's certainly the
three-story list of buildings the
cottage that you can just see the
chimneys on
is is a similar total height but
um yeah it is higher i think from the
fourth
that we have that you got from around
the site that
where there are viewpoints away those
derrick buildings are realized
in the valley yeah so overall
i mean i think members and certainly
great toronton town council have put
three responses
to the applications over the period
do accept everybody accepts this is
going to be a huge improvement
to that area dereliction gone and
the comprehensive development of it all
and i think as council christie
has mentioned one of the key things
is the phasing of the development that
we're not going to get
any cherry picking demo but that that
um you know the demolition's got to be
done before planets are built
who were phased in with the direction of
eddie dwellings
so unless anybody else has anything they
want to have
[Music]
and it's been removed but i'm going to
go to each individual application
and have to take an individual
constitution
can i actually
[Music]
[Music]
across the four applications before you
today but the the hybrid commission
would need to feature in with that as
well and would you
want to write into that yeah this review
mechanism
probably well yeah
so yeah page 44 i think
it is of my my report
second paragraph um which is
my recommendation for the comprehensive
scheme in terms of viability
and it says um this however should be on
the basis of the review mechanisms as
recommended by the dv
being included within the associated
legal agreement so i think there's two
there's two recommendations for review
mechanisms the key one which we wouldn't
normally
include is wholly relevant is
the need to review at the point of
demolition being completed and
assessing those those significant costs
because mr gill said that's a big ticket
the viability of and then after
after the first generation yeah um
i think that would come out through the
negotiations um
which obviously the board members would
be involved in as well in terms of what
of what phases we would then
reasonably look to review through the
development
okay that's right can we go to the first
application
to be decided to long time his
application modernly
zero five two six twenty twenty
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um there was a discussion about an
amendment the condition
for the disability access regardless oh
yeah and that condition was in relation
to zero
uh application zero five two six and
zero five two eight
um i'm not sure what numbers conditions
do we have
four condition four on um
oh five two six
[Music]
and i'll find the other one for when we
come
[Music]
the sake of completeness we do have to
change separately just in case there is
any deviation
right can we go on that first
application for everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh reserve matters application yeah
can everybody in favor of granting that
one patient
and that is unanimous too thank you
next application the full application
which is 1.0524
2020 it's a full application council
wants us to go
catch the ground step to grant that one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
that is unanimous thank you
thank you for everybody
[Music]
and the gender item 10
which is delegating decisions on aging
and b applications
there's one or two of the three ways
planning decisions made between the 22nd
of may 21
and the 12th july 21
205 206
210 211
[Music]
and the ones
uh i'm sure sean knows what i'm going to
be talking about yeah
it's the second refusal a second lawful
use has been refused
now i've got one in my ward at the
moment where
the local news has been put in and when
i
called it in because it appeared on my
list of week again
i was told i couldn't call it in because
it's a merely legal thing
and i ask when can i challenge it then
and i'll say well you can't it's just
and yet here i see one's being reviewed
can i ask them when does this
challenge who's challenged it and why
can't i challenge that
it's being refused by the officer
yeah um i don't know the actual details
of this certificate
and so i can't have it it's just a
principle
so the principal certificate is there's
it's not a planning application it says
no planning merit
it's determined by an officer um on the
basis of the evidence provided
now you'll be aware that certificates
have historically and do
part of your weekly list so you're aware
of when circuits come in
as there's no planning mode what we look
at and the purpose of that is if you
have any evidence to the contrary or to
support
that specification then that can be
provided it is
a legal judgment it's not a judgmental
planning merits
so that's your opportunity if you see
one of your and this is to all members
if you do see one of your planning lists
like you feel like you've got evidence
that agrees with it or disagrees with it
then you can supply that evidence
and it's a purely illegal judgment
i have had in six letters
thank you so much
now i must say
[Music]
as well the planning performance figures
for the last quarter
i was very impressed with we set
our standards above the government
criteria
and i was very impressed with the
performance
about planning department of that
quarter
and you'll see from having just read
through all those planning applications
now
that uh how busy the department is
a heck of a visit and again this one
this one we just dealt with before
applications brought together
the generally been immensely similar and
i do congratulate
helen and the plans department have been
a massive
thing to deal with and it has gone over
a while because
there's been so many various aspects to
pull in
asking for evidence or information from
certain applicants sometimes and we
don't respond it's been a nightmare to
be
[Music]
thank you to all the officers for
attending this morning
and special thanks for watching
man we're